nachrichten des tages
mit niedriger ihnen allen guten abend
sportliches in der sendung später wieder
mit kristin otto in acht minuten guten
abend unsere themen an diesem sonntag
not und verzweiflung in mariupol und
anderen umkämpften städten gehen die
russischen angriffe weiter
weg vom russischen gas
wirtschaftsminister habeck vereinbart
eine energiepartnerschaft mit katar
und sound of peace beim großen
solidaritätskonzert für die ukraine am
brandenburger tor setzten tausende ein
zeichen für den frieden
die russischen angriff auf strategisch
wichtige ukrainische städte werden mit
aller härte fortgesetzt vor diesem krieg
den papst franziskus ein sinnloses
massaker nennt fliehen immer mehr
menschen laut vereinten nationen sind es
inzwischen rund zehn millionen gut ein
drittel von ihnen flüchtete ins ausland
seit tagen unter dauerbeschuss die
hafenstadt mario pohl dort beginnt der
beitrag von alexandra vacano und
alexandra schenk
es ist der fünfundzwanzigste tag in
diesem krieg hier kämpfen ukrainische
gegen russische soldaten in mariupol das
sollen die aufnahmen ukrainischer
streitkräfte zeigen
die von russen belagerte hafenstadt seit
wochen unter dauerbeschuss mario pohl
sei zerstört die lage dort katastrophal
so das ukrainische innenministerium
das ort stahlwerk eines der größten
europas würde gerade zugute
die blockade von mario pohl wird als
kriegsverbrechen in die geschichte
eingehen was die besatzer einer
friedlichen stadt angetan haben ist ein
terrorakt an dem man sich noch
jahrhunderte lang erinnern wird
die die können verlassen mario pohl rund
40.000 hätten es in dieser woche
geschafft laut stadtrat aber tausende
würden auch gegen ihren willen nach
russland gebracht werden überprüfen
lässt sich das nicht angriffe in der
nacht auch in kharkiv von dort erzählt
uns maria affe war über diesen krieg
sonntag
ich war heute im stadtzentrum es wird
immer leerer es sind immer weniger
menschen in der stadt es wirkt alles so
apokalyptisch
es ist auch ein krieg der bilder das
russische militär veröffentlicht diese
aufnahmen von angriffen auf die
ukrainische armee aufklärungs einheiten
und munitionslager angeblich die ziele
gestern ein raketenangriff auf eine
kaserne in der region von nicola häffner
odessa hier sollen sie mindestens 50
tote geborgen haben in der nähe heute
beobachtet unsere reporterin hier von
nikolaus kam die russischen panzer auf
die stadt zugerollt sie konnten nur an
der weiterfahrt gehindert werden weil
die ukrainische armee hier die brücke
gesprengt hat die einwohner hier müssen
jetzt zu fuß gehen ein leben in
ständiger angst
auf der suche nach ersatz für russisches
gas ist wirtschaftsminister habe im kata
erfolgreich gewesen er hat dort nach
eigenen angaben eine langfristige
energiepartnerschaft vereinbaren können
durchaus umstritten weil es immer wieder
kritik an der menschenrechtslage gibt
der golfstaat verfügt nach russland und
iran über die weltweit größten
erdgasreserven mehr von karl
hinterleitner
es geht um energie es geht um
menschenrechte und es geht um
unabhängigkeit von russischem gas
flüssiggas vom golf vor allem aus katar
soll helfen die zu erreichen am mittag
traf sich robert habeck mit dem emir von
katar die atmosphäre so hieß es war gut
der minister anschließend geradezu
euphorisch großartiger weise und das war
ja das ziel jeden tag des besuchs in
katark kann ich sagen das fest
vereinbart wurde eine langfristige
energie partnerschaft eine kooperation
einzugehen und die unternehmen die jetzt
auf diesem wege mit dabei sind werden
jetzt mit der katarischen seite wenn die
vertragsverhandlungen tief einsteigen
das who ist who der deutschen
energiewirtschaft ist mit auf reisen
gegangen hab ich's besuch auch ein
türöffner für die industrie und das
trotz offener fragen vor ort zb über
demokratie und menschenrechte
robert habeck begibt sich bei seiner
reise an den golf eine politische grad
einerseits will eine atmosphäre schaffen
die die dringend nötigen energie
geschäfte ermöglicht andererseits muss
er die menschenrechte ansprechen das hat
er wohl auch getan aber wohl nicht allzu
deutlich denn das würde wieder die
geschäfte gefährden man nennt das
realpolitik denn deutschland braucht die
energien aus der region heute abend
reist die delegation in die vereinigten
arabischen emirate wenn es gut läuft
dann hat deutschland bei dieser reise
zwei neue energielieferant gewonnen
wegen hoher spritpreise berät die ampel
koalition offenbar über hilfen für
kleine und mittlere einkommen laut bild
am sonntag hat arbeitsminister heil ein
sogenanntes mobilitäts geld ins spiel
gebracht das mit dem gehalt überwiesen
wird über die höhe werde noch gerungen
in der diskussion monatlich 20 bis 50
euro mehr für einkommen bis maximal 4000
euro topverdiener gingen demnach leer
aus in einer kleinen gemeinde in süd
belgien endete eine
karnevalsveranstaltung in einer tragödie
mit hoher geschwindigkeit raste ein auto
in eine menschenansammlung mindestens
sechs menschen starben zehn weitere
wurden lebensgefährlich verletzt die
beiden insassen des wagens wurden
festgenommen laut staatsanwaltschaft
gibt es keine
weise auf einen terroristischen
hintergrund
sie wissen seit heute entfallen einige
corona maßnahmen so brauchen
bahnreisende keinen 3g nachweis mehr
außerdem gibt es keine gesetzliche
pflicht mehr für 3g nachweise am
arbeitsplatz binnen 24 stunden
registrierte das robert-koch-institut
1792 neuinfektionen 14.800 15 weniger
als vergangenen sonntag 49 todesfälle
kamen hinzu die sieben tage incidents
ist erstmals seit mehr als zwei wochen
gesunken auf etwa
demonstrieren gegen den krieg auch an
diesem wochenende sind es in deutschland
wieder tausende die ein ende der
angriffe auf die ukraine fordern wir
hier zum beispiel heute in hamburg die
deutsche kultur und musik szene zeigt in
berlin flagge mit der aktion sound of
peace vor dem brandenburger tor
stephanie heim war dabei
nicht wollen
um liebe zu zeigen
tausende hände strecken sich in den
berliner himmel als zeichen der
verbundenheit mit der ukraine
[Musik]
in nur zwei wochen haben die
veranstalter diese friedenskundgebung
auf die beine gestellt ich finde musik
war schon immer dafür da protest zu
äußern und eben aber auch den
zusammenhalt der menschen zu beschwören
und genau das ist heute in perfektion
hier passiert es ist hier wirklich ein
ganz schönes und herzerwärmendes gefühl
dass man sieht wie viele menschen hier
für die schöne sache zusammengekommen
sind für friede und für liebe im zeichen
zu setzen und dann eben noch gelder zu
sammeln für den guten zweck wenn jede
stadt jede landwirt sowie berlin heute
auf steht dann können wir zusammen was
wir gegen ich glaube daran ich bin fest
überzeugt
[Musik]
natalia klitschko die frau des kiewer
bürgermeister singt über ihr
angegriffenes land und alle hoffen dass
der krieg beendet und sammeln spenden
für organisationen die den ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer jetzt helfen
und wenn auch sie spenden möchten so
könnte es gehen über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe iban de 65 104 106 100
104 106 100 zdf nothilfe ukraine das
stichwort alle infos zum nachlesen
spenden
zdf.de und auf der zdf textseite 890
wir sind beim sport wir sind beim
saisonende im biathlon da gab es viele
emotionen herr abschied und jubel
versöhnlicher abschluss des olympia
winters für franziska preuß als zweite
im weltcup massenstart von oslo
teamkollege erik lesser verpasst zwar
diesmal das podest knapp beeindruckt
dabei erneut und sagt endgültig bei bei
seinen letzten zieleinlauf genießt erik
lesser sichtlich als bester deutscher
landete heute auf dem vierten platz
verabschiedet wird er unter anderem von
einer die es kurz vorher im massenstart
sogar auf rang zwei geschafft hat nach
einer saison mit verletzungen corona
infektion und selbstzweifeln feiert
franziska preuß im letzten
saisonauftritt den ersten podestplatz
diesem winter dank ihrer starken
laufleistung hinter der olympiasiegerin
system britta busch ii damit beenden die
deutschen frauen die saison mit sechs
podestplätzen
erfolgreiches weltcup-finale auch für
die deutsche snowboard mannschaft zum
krönenden abschluss setzte sich in
berchtesgaden in nicks teamwettbewerb
stefan baumeister und ramona hofmeister
im parallelslalom gegen sabine
schöffmann alexander peya aus österreich
durch
[Musik]
zum fussball im ersten sonntagsspiel der
bundesliga trennen sich leipzig und
frankfurt 0 zu 0 rb vorläufig
tabellendritter die eintracht auf platz
acht und überraschung zum auftakt der
neuen formel-1-saison mit einem
doppelsieg für ferrari endet der erste
wm lauf beim großen preis von bahrain
charles' claire im ferrari rechts
gewinnt von der poleposition aus den
staat weltmeister max verstaubten lange
zeit dicht an seinem heck mitte des
rennens mehrere attacken des
niederländers doch der monegasse content
bleibt vorne die entscheidung drei
runden vor rennende verstappen mit
technischen defekt raus bahn frei für
schale claire erster grand-prix-sieg der
scuderia seit 910 tagen auf zwei carlos
sainz junior ebenfalls ferrari lewis
hamilton wird dritter mit schumacher
guter elfter
schon kommende woche geht es in saudi
arabien weiter dankeschön christin wir
haben jetzt noch fix dem blick aufs
wetter
morgen gibt es im nordwesten wolken
sonst aber sonnig der südostwind weht
mäßig aber durch die temperatur erreicht
an der ostsee 10 19 grad werden es am
niederrhein die nächsten tage sehr viel
sonne temperaturen zwischen 11 und 20
grad